a Las Vegas city councilwoman is
breaking ranks within the city manager
at a press conference today councilwoman
Victoria Seaman said a proposed new city
ordinance violates open meeting laws
requiring a fiscal or city manager to
review a proposal before it goes to the
council semen telling reporters that it
gives city manager Jorge Cervantes the
ability to recommend or not recommended
ordinances to the council
Mr Cervantes is entirely outside his job
description as city manager and
attempting to use his position to
silence elected officials
now that video came directly from
councilwoman Seaman who tells 8 news now
that the reason for the change is
because of a controversial pet breeding
bill that was passed at the very most
recent council meeting councilman Brian
cadutson says the ordinance would
provide the council with more
information the council will discuss the
matter during their meeting that meeting
is tomorrow